Cedric Leighton is
a CNN military analyst and retired U.S.
Air Force colonel.
He joins us now from Washington.
Good to see you, sir.
Good to see you, too, John.
Let's start
with that attack on Russian soil
now, according to Michael Colburn,
a researcher
with the investigative Web site
Bellingcat.
The Russian volunteer corps,
led by a figure
well known to him
and those who follow the transnational
far right, Dennis Capuchin.
Now, the Anti-Defamation
League says Dennis
Capuchin is a Russian neo-Nazi
who lived in Germany
for many years, has trained
young members of the far right
national Democratic Party
of Germany and others
who also have ties to the as obviously
in the assault brigades,
which is a Ukrainian extremist
far right group as well.
So when Putin actually goes public,
he insists
the attack was carried out by neo-Nazis.
There's an element of truth
of that statement
and what the Ukrainian military
may have nothing to do with this.
This is a big problem.
It's a major issue.
They have to deal with
Yeah, it certainly is, John.
And, you know,
when you look at
this gentleman's pedigree,
you notice that he's trained
the members
of the youth
wing of the NPD Party in Germany,
which is a successor to the Nazi Party.
So there are some
some real issues that the Ukrainians
have to be very careful with,
because in this war,
quite frankly,
images, everything,
and it becomes important
for them to be as clean as possible
and as, you know, show as many Democratic
tendencies as possible in order to fight
a war.
It is very important for them
to follow all the rules of armed conflict
to a Geneva Convention
and anything that smacks of them
not doing so.
I can be very detrimental
to the Ukrainian cause Yeah.
And there are so many foreign fighters
who flock to Ukraine just for,
you know, the battle or whatever.
That is an issue as well.
But
this wheat obsession
that the Russians have right now
of capturing Buckwheat.
It looks like it may be coming to an end
game here on Tuesday.
An adviser
to the Ukrainian president signaled
what seems to be a change in tactics.
He was talking to CNN.
Here he is
Our military is obviously going
to weigh of the options so far.
You know,
they hope to help the city,
but if need be,
they will strategically pull back
because we're not going to sacrifice
all of our people just for nothing.
So it will be
a strategic step by the military,
which is a bit of a shift
because there's always been
this will fight to
the end, will hold it to the end.
But at the same time,
Ukraine is sending more troops
into the fight there.
So that seems like there's
a few things happening here
that could be all part of disinformation.
The extra troops could be there
to defend the city.
They could provide cover for a retreat
or they could be
part of a counter-offensive.
How do you see all of this
Yeah, I
think it's the most
strategic retreat at this point in time
because I don't see the Ukrainians having
all the logistics in place
for a counteroffensive
Of course, they could surprise us.
And, you know,
anything is possible in warfare.
But at this point in time,
it looks like the best course of action
for the Ukraine
would be to mount a strategic retreat,
pull the forces back just enough
so that they aren't
impacted by the encirclement moves
that the Russians
are actually executing
right now, a run off mode.
How does an early spring thaw fall
into all of this? How's that play to it?
Because what was frozen
territory or trade flows
and ground is now mud.
Yeah, that's true.
And in fact,
the winter in Ukraine
has generally been warmer
than it normally is.
So you're dealing with a lot of mud
more now than you would normally deal
with at point in time in the year.
So there is that factor.
There is also the factor of
the troop fatigue that it is
a key issue for the Ukrainians
and also for the Russians to some extent.
But the Russians
have much
greater manpower resources, John.
That's what you're seeing here,
that they're bringing them to bear.
You know, we're
coupled with the Wagner group
that is creating a real problem
for the Ukrainian defenders of just.
Yeah.
Just very quickly,
you know, the Russians have a staggering
loss, is trying to take this city.
At the end of the day,
they win the battle but lose
the war because of this
Most certainly.
And in fact,
this could very well
prove to be a Pyrrhic victory
for the Russians.
They have staked so much on both mud
that I think
really putting too much into this
from a military standpoint.
And it could very well result
in great losses for them.
And it could also put them
at a significant disadvantage
going forward.
Colonel, as always, say,
thank you so much.
Good to have you with us.
You bet, John. Any time.